not only is this striking in the sense
of using baptism and Eucharist as
sacraments or rituals which are
certainly more associated with Orthodox
Christianity which this text and those
like it seem to reject so strongly
although it seems pretty clear that they
interpret these rituals in some
different ways but it's also striking in
invoking this Bridal chamber among such
rituals seemingly indicating that it too
involves some kind of practice maybe
even some kind of sexual one the idea
that these quote unquote Gnostic groups
performed some kind of sexual rituals
was often used as a kind of argument by
their enemies to discredit the movement
for example in his classic text against
the heresies irus says quote for some of
them prepare a bridal chamber and
perform a sort of Mystic right
pronouncing certain expressions with
those who are being initiated and affirm
that it is a spiritual marriage which is
celebrated by them after the likeness of
the conjunctions above